all right let's go through the list the
rapidly growing it's almost impossible
to keep up with the growing list of
vaccine requirements and mandates now
coming forward
from
uh educational institutions
employers
um states with regard to state workers
all happening very quickly in the
aftermath of the pfizer covid vaccine
receiving full fda approval something
sort of a watershed moment that was
weighted uh awaited by many on both the
pro and anti-vaccine sides the
anti-vaccines either hoping it wouldn't
happen or saying
if it happens then i will get vaccinated
let's see if they do and of course those
of us on the pro-vaccine side
waiting for what was obviously going to
happen with the hope that it will help
get us out of the pandemic now we've
already talked about the pentagon
announcing all 1.3 million u.s service
members will be required to be
vaccinated we don't know the exact
timeline yet presumably it will be a
couple of months but the military will
be vaccinating all active duty service
members we've previously also talked
about new york city bill de blasio the
mayor in new york city enacting mandates
for indoor dining and a ton of other
leisure and entertainment um activities
in the state of new york over the
weekend and the city of new york rather
over the weekend there was a very very
extreme anti-vaccine a protest maybe
we'll look at some clips of that
tomorrow it's a little difficult to
watch quite frankly the cringe is high
and the delusions are even higher uh but
let's look at some of the other
requirements that are now being put in
place and speaking of new york the new
york city public schools organization
has issued a full coveted vaccine
mandate for all staff you want to work
at new york city schools public schools
you want to teach at new york city
public schools you will have to be
vaccinated that'll take effect september
27th
and uh all education employees will be
required to upload proof of at least the
first dose
to an online portal
going from
new york to texas texas instruments a
for-profit company in texas will require
all u.s based employees to get the
covid19 vaccine they are based in dallas
it is a
it's really a semiconductor company
although i know texas instruments for
those graphing calculators that were
so much fun in high school math they
will be required both employees and
contractors will be required to be
vaccinated by october 29th otherwise
they will lose their jobs
disney has reached a deal with the
service trades council union to require
all of its unionized employees
working at walt disney world in florida
to be fully vaccinated by october 22nd
of 2021 fully vaccinated presumably
meaning both doses meaning at the latest
they will have to get that first dose uh
in that's in the second half of
september uh remember that last month
disney mandated all of its salary and
non-union hourly employees get
vaccinated by the end of september and
now a deal for all of the union
employees to be vaccinated as well
anecdotally in seattle there are now
more than 130 different bars and
restaurants requiring vaccine proof
and that list is growing relatively
quickly expected to be even faster now
with full vaccine approval
and then we also have a bunch of
different stories out of new jersey new
jersey is going to require covet
vaccination for teachers and for state
workers the governor there is phil
murphy a democrat he announced the
mandate
during a news conference i believe
yesterday
pre-k through 12th grade teachers and
staff and state employees
must be fully vaccinated by october 18th
or they will have to get tested once or
twice a week
now
the testing or vaccine i'm not really
big on it
um but there are places that are doing
it it's sort of a softer vaccine
requirement to say if you're not you
will have to be tested once or twice a
week and then for something completely
different coming just showing the the
breadth of places we are seeing these
requirements navajo nation
has now issued a vaccine mandate for
tribal workers
this is happening the question now is
what are the resistors going to do
some of them are just going to go and
get vaccinated without question but are
there some folks that will actually quit
a job
over a vaccine requirement
are they more likely to fake their
vaccination results will they are we
going to see lawsuits come forward
saying that this is a violation of
who knows what but just some kind of
legal attempt to resist this is going to
become a huge issue now the easiest
thing from the standpoint of just like
do i go and find a fake vaccine card do
i hire a lawyer and file a lawsuit or
whatever the case may be the easiest
thing continues to be just go and get
vaccinated it's even easier to actually
get vaccinated than to fake a vaccine
card it's legal as opposed to faking a
vaccine card and it provides you with
some protection particularly against
serious coveted hospitalization or death
so it's much more useful than a fake
vaccine card
one more thought on this former guest on
the show radley balco it's been years
but radley was a guest on the program i
think more than a decade ago he had a
funny but relevant tweet
where he said here's an idea
set aside 15 million pfizer vaccines
give them a weird new name
like hydroxy iversink
send them to doctors and veterinarians
and acupuncturists
and run a viral marketing campaign
calling hydroxy iversink the secret
covered cure the government doesn't want
you to know about
that might actually work it's the type
of thing that might actually work um and
quite frankly if you want to have these
people go and get vaccinated
start claiming joe biden's going to ban
the vaccine
these people will go and get vaccinated
the next day
if they believe joe biden is going to
ban it because if joe biden supports
something it must be bad
and if joe biden wants to ban something
it must be good i would actually look
into that the ethics of it i don't know
but it certainly would be effective